welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss spoiler warning for one division
finale episode
this baby had two post-credits scenes
that we gotta talk about one of which
i'm gonna talk about with jess and
inside marvel where you'll
be able to see my raw reaction in this
episode but the second
we gotta talk about here because there's
no time to waste okay so you watch the
episode by now you know after defeating
agatha trapping her in westview erasing
the hex along with vision and her boys
and soaring off as an apparently more
villainous scarlet witch
wanda retires to what looks like a
sokovian mountain cabin
odd patterns that look like runes on the
walls but
inside a second wanda a darker wanda
flipping through the dark hold as the
voices of billy and tommy beg her for
help
now interestingly the music here is the
theme of doctor strange
funnily enough composed by michael
jacquino who did the main marvel studios
title theme that we've been hearing
every single episode of wandavision as
it opens and obviously doctor strange
this episode was setting up wanted to
face off with
and dr strange's multiverse of madness
agatha explicitly said the scarlet
witch's powers surpassed those of even
the sorcerer supreme
and she warned wanda about what she had
unleashed question mark question mark
now i know what you are going to say so
boss where was my
physto idiot i know i really got carried
away on that mephisto train didn't i
i thought i was pizza time peter and i
could stop it before it derailed but
really i was marty mcfly trying to blast
the f out of there as the train crashed
behind me into a ravine
except i'm still on that train
let me tell you the fire down here feels
so
warm why am i still in the train well
not only did a page of that darkhold
appear to show another dark creepy
figure on the left side of the book when
agatha was looking through it
not only did a red light lens flare
flash in the closing frame
to look like red eyes beyond wanda and
not only does a mephisto figure appear
in that stained glass in the loki
trailer
but those boys crying for help it is
still
possible these kids could be pieces of
mephisto's soul folks
demon spawn but a question not answered
in one division a question perhaps gonna
be answered in multiverse of madness but
i know i'm sounding crazy so let me back
up
and try to explain how this insane
mephisto train got started you know i
gotta say staring at the screen so hard
to find all these easter eggs is doing a
number on my vision
but some people have been really helping
me with that our friends at blue blocks
thanks to blue blocks for sponsoring
this video so at the end of the day of
staring at screens it's really hard to
settle my eyes just to fall asleep no
matter how hard you try it's just really
hard to get your bedroom 100 dark at
night
more light is coming in through the
curtains there are tiny lights on all
your electronic devices
maybe your pet glows since that
industrial accident sorry darla
all that lightning room makes it really
hard to fall asleep and harder to stay
asleep
wow the blue blocks remedy sleep mask is
the solution
this baby creates 100 darkness and is
super comfortable it's got adjustable
eye
cups for that perfect fit and it works
whether you sleep on your belly or on
your side or on your back and you can
fully open your eyes with it on like i
have my eyes open
right now you creeped out maybe you
should stop watching me while i sleep my
fisto you've already disappointed me in
so many other ways
i have used other sleep masks before but
they were never as comfortable or as
effective as this blue blocks remedy
sleep mask
whether you're looking to improve your
sleep help with medication or get some
rest while traveling these masks are
awesome go to blueblocks.com
new rockstars or click the link below
and get 20 off your remedy sleep masks
today
my code is automatically applied for
that 20 off so all you need to do is
click on the link below to get the best
sleep of your life possible right now
grab yourself a blue box remedy sleep
mask just go to b
l u b l o x dot com slash new rockstars
or click the link below to get 20
off your order code automatically
applied at check out one division's
director matt shakman in an interview
with comicbook.com this week
signaled two fans that they should brace
themselves for finale reveals that
might not live up to their theories i
hope people find it um
both surprising but inevitable you know
the idea i hate stories that
pivot you know 180 at the last minute
and you're like what have i been
watching this whole time
you know agatha christie novels where
the murderer someone you just met pops
in you're like come on why did i read
this whole thing
but you could totally argue that like a
great agatha christie mystery
clues were laid out consistently
throughout the episodes pointing to
mephisto
and that rather than someone we just met
he did feel like a presence that was
with
us from the beginning all along the
whole time the mepisto train
really left the station back in august
2019
a month after kevin feige introduced one
division at comic-con
and now catherine hahn was announced at
d23 to be plain a quote
nosy neighbor and immediately fans begin
to speculate that that could mean the
witch agatha harkness
arguably the most important female
relationship wanda maximov has in the
comics and agatha being part of one of
vision meant a very strong possibility
that marvel's devil mephisto might show
up as well
one of the most famous wanda and vision
storylines was the west coast avengers
run in the late 80s
in which wanda's children billy and
tommy are revealed to be pieces of
mephisto's soul in a plot
in which agatha brainwashes this memory
from wanda's mind and this wasn't just
some obscure comic book issue that no
one ever read
it's a critical turning point in wanda's
journey it's so crucial that elizabeth
olsen even
cited this in a scarlet witch historical
summary right as civil war came out back
in may 2016.
scarlet witch had her very own marvel
immaculate conception
she used magic to make herself pregnant
and gave birth to twin boys the vision
had his memory wiped
he and scarlett got a divorce and the
twins turned out to be shards of the
demon nephisto
almost five years ago folks juana
maximov herself pretty much described
the plot of wandavision
and add that to the fact that mephisto's
name showed up as an easter egg in the
first avengers film in 2012 and the way
thanos's minion ebony mod directly
quoted mephisto from the infinity
gauntlet comics
my humble personage
bows before your grandeur and it is
clear that marvel studios at least has
had mephisto on the brain for several
years but then that mobisto train hit
that first speed boost in february 2020
when one division's first promo footage
revealed this series would indeed
introduce her sons billy and tommy
and then another speed boost in october
2020 when catherine han's character was
named
agnes in a trailer a name we correctly
id'd as a cross-eyed amalgamation of
agatha harkness and so in january when
one division premiered many of us were
primed to be on a very sharp lookout for
mephisto
or really anything that moved so that we
could point to it and scream my vest out
and right out of the gate in episode one
agnes mentioned her off-screen husband
ralph the only way ralph would remember
our anniversary is if there was a beer
named june
2nd june 2nd was the date the salem
witch trials began in 1692
and then boom episode 8 confirmed agatha
as a salem witch
getting roasted by her own coven one
year later in 1693.
agnes also says the devil's in the
details bev
that's not the only place he is yeah
what does that mean
like if agnes was referring to dottie or
her booze nothing came out of those
which left this is a pretty solid
mephisto clue and then midway through
the season paul bettany was asked about
mephisto
and played super coy about it in the
interview i can't speak to
right now because i'm worried about
getting fired and then in episode six
theatre says unleash hell demons
after devil in the details this was our
biggest clue yet that the boys billy and
tommy could actually be
pieces spawn from the demon mephisto and
then episode seven steered
hard into witchcraft by revealing it was
agatha
all along with a rabbit incapable of
being scanned by telepath billy agatha
revealed she hijacked west view using
dark magic
from that evil spell book the demonic
darkhold from a dungeon
covered in satanic imagery including a
horned ram's head on the wall
episode 8 opens with a full-on salem
witch trial now historically the witches
of salem were persecuted for
suspected romantic affiliations with the
devil which is considered themselves to
be lovers and wives of satan these
witches also cast spells
in the language of latin
tying their witchcraft to christian
cultural influences
the same fire and brimstone imagery that
marvel based mephisto
on and now in the finale episode a lot
of the things we thought could have been
clues were actually pointing in other
directions like
agnes off-screen husband ralph ended up
being a borderline insulting rugpul
making evan peters fietro
an aspiring actor named ralph boner
cannot wait to see what the fox quick
silver fans do with that one
senor scratchy nowhere to be found but
still
those boys the boys perhaps still
demon spawn because of their cries from
the darkhold
something with a fiery orange glow
emanating off of it also earlier in the
episode wanda said
thanks for choosing me to be your mom
now yes i got
way too trigger thinking mephisto could
appear in wandavision obviously this is
not a show about mephisto it was a show
about wanda
and skrulls but darker forces remain out
there
the table is set and i am still leaving
the chair open for the devil
just either in loki or multiverse of
madness no regrets hey if you haven't
already this is our unusual couple's
shirt it's about to sell out so this is
your last chance to get one of these
just go to newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter eddie of us
follow new rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for everything one division
thanks for watching
[Music]
you